mon père a appelé la mon frère mon père
appelé mon frère quand je suis arrivé à
malte et p c'est
un choc des cultures parce que
européens américains et pas exactement
la même culture que que en turquie mais
aussi cessé s'adapter à 50 ou 60
personnalités complètement différente
que qui était tellement à l'ouest de
monde monde de mon univers donc ça
c'était un peu ça c'était très très très
dur
alors là très vite en prison tu es
conditions de détention vont se dégrader
et devenir terrible puisque dans une
première prison tu fait de victime d'une
tentative de meurtre
d'agression physique on va dire ce qui
s'est passé on m'a envoyé un de l'eau
bouillante sur le visage sur le corps
ça ans en réseautique je crois pas je je
je
on m'a dit il m'a dit on m'a dit de 2
que c'était pour ma religion comme l'a
été aussi condamnées pour il ya eu six
mois et plus une à une amende assez
importante il a été condamné par la cour
enfin la le tribunal en prison mais bon
comme il avait 125 ans à purger pour lui
c'était pas grand chose c'était c'était
un bonus on va dire ça c'est ça qui a
été visée peut donc pas ce que tu étais
tu dis aussi été visée parce que tu
était juif et homosexuel aussi dans la
page je pense dans la foulée s'adresse à
un pas du jour en ma faveur
les conditions c'était quoi les
conditions de détention
c'était
très dur mais je sais pas je sais pas
comment comment vous expliquer parce que
je n'hésite pas d'autre chose at un jeu
pourrait le comparer avec la france mais
ça a tellement rien à voir que que quand
arrivé en prison en france tu t'es dit
sais
c'est quoi ça c'est complètement
différent sanaa veut ça n'avait rien à
voir avec la turquie déjà les les les
surveillants turquie ont le droit que
vous vous tapez d'accord alors qu'en
france il n'y a pas de ça et c'est un
système à la militaire donc huit heures
c'est l'heure 8h01 c'est plus l'heure si
vous avez passé vos hivers si vous
arrivez en retard pour l'appel de huit
heures ben on les surveille on vous tape
alors qu'en france les appels c'est
entre entre 7 heures et 7 heures 20 ce
qui est assez relax on va dire mais
c'est ça reste quand même la prison mais
disons on n'a pas peur de se faire moi
j'avais plus peur en france de me faire
taper par les surveillants c'était quoi
le moment le plus dur
quand le juge en prison ou horizon
d'abord cette agression déjà à cette
agression c'est l'agression et je vois
encore les yeux de mon agresseur l'a la
haine alors que le titre je le
connaissais jusque le sait ni son nom je
l'avais il est hélas non dans la cellule
pendant deux jours avant de l'agresser
et connaissez rien sur moi je ne
connaissais rien sur lui j'avais même
pas un organe ne s'était même pas
croisés
et donc
donc l'agression reste un moment assez
difficile à me remémorer et
le moment où le juge m'a donné 20 ans
enfin ton triste d'un temps qu'elles ont
été ramenés à 16 ans et huit mois pour
pour bon comportement à l'audience où
une audience qui a duré quand même 15
minutes enfin en étant reconnu et en
étant généreux alors tu vas être ensuite
déplacé tués détenus à 800 km au
nord-est d'istanbul dans une prison
difficile d'accès où tu partage sa
cellule avec huit autres co détenus là
au début oui d'accord oui ça se passe
mieux pour toi là-bas oui mais c'est
je suis pas resté très longtemps cette
cellule ils nous ont aidés ils ont
éclaté la cellule très rapidement quand
est-ce qu'on était tous étrangers est en
fait il voulait intégrer giresun était
une prison à 90% turc donc il voulait
soit que les autorités pénitentiaires
voulait soit que nous apprenions aux
turcs qui étaient pas vraiment possible
pour pour d'autres raisons soit que nous
enseignons l'anglais ou le français ou
l'espagnol aux eaux turques ce qui
n'était pas possible donc et et en fait
on disait et éclater la cellule de de
lui perdre on était neuf dans la cellule
où huit puces mois neuf et ils ont ils
nous ont mis dans une cellule qui était
à majoritairement turc et là on a été
ces têtes et et c'était très dur parce
que les montagnes et sont pas du tout
les mêmes et parce que là la télévision
n'était qu'en turc toute façon y avait
pas une seule chaîne intéressant
internationale donc pour nous pour les
étrangers en été de 4,5 dans la dans la
cellule étrangère c'était encore plus
dur tu as vécu des moments encore
difficile à des agressions des danseurs
physiques et morales physiques non non
après celle ci mais je pense que je
mange m'en rappelle j'ai encore le que
le corps pour me rappeler